okay four people joining this livestream
we are reviewing pieces of experimental
functionality morph language and trying
to figure out what it will take to make
them not experimental anymore
so first up for this morning the
compiler so these things are not
experimental but their functionality is
still far from what it will ultimately
be um I mean so there's what is there to
discuss here I mean these are or they
they are currently tagged as
experimental they are currently tagged I
mean that's change I'm not I just don't
think that they're robust enough I mean
I think that there you can't expect to
function in the wild to compile that's
really the criterion I mean the function
is what okay fine whatever then that's
not that's that's fine why do you think
that they should be do experimental eyes
well because I think they're quite
robust and they produce good good code
well I understand that um
I mean in that sense they're far from
experimental well so compiled code
function I considerably not that
experimental right yeah
but but Tom that just people are not
going to think these up you know that
they're not finished that's fine with me
does it I have an opinion about this
I I don't have a super strong opinion I
mean I think in terms of sort of is the
design of these functions likely to
change no it's probably not but I agree
functionality is is far from what it
will be right so the question is is that
I mean I often are criterion for the
experimental icing is that the design is
fixed you could say that about nd
solving version you know 1.2 - you know
you know it does unbelievably more now
than it did know I'm thinking about it
I'm thinking about it I mean look I
don't want people to think that they're
compiled code functions are gonna stop
working because they're not yeah on the
other hand I don't want people to try
function compiled and say this doesn't
compile my code I'm not interested and
then go away for 10 years and not try it
again
see what I'm saying sure
I guess what one possible benchmark is
how far do we think we are from
compiling sort of down value-based
functions well you know the e-type some
of the that function compiled
takes a function so it's kind of
irrelevant for that right which means
it's not do we know the design for when
we're going to do down value compilation
what will that design look like I I'm
unclear on that it'll probably get
collections of symbols yeah well it's
probably compiled symbol compiled or
some such other thing something like
that maybe yes well I mean why can't
function compile take a symbol and
assume that it's compiling the down
values of that symbol well first of all
because function compile is not hold all
but if you just give it the symbol right
anymore yeah I mean it's a start
if we're going to start compiling own
values that's maybe something else but
that's kind of stupid yeah exactly
um fair point um yeah I mean that would
not be inconsistent
um
one question though Yaya the problem is
this returns a compiled code function
right what does it return or what does
it do in the down value case it could
return something like an association if
there's no but I understand but that's
not very useful what you actually want
it to do is to replace the definition of
F when it can with a compile definition
well that's not function compile I
understand that but I don't think it's
particularly useful I mean what's it
gonna do it's going to I mean look one
way to do it one way to do this is the
following okay um
okay so I have an idea
okay so what we could do is function
compile
of F could give you something which is
cold compiled function
it's compiled function what is compiled
function what is that well that's the
legacy compiler so okay well it could
make one function that overloads all the
different versions into one thing and
has the dispatching code what I
understand I understand that I
understand that so what I'm suggesting
as a headdress approach um
just imagine this is called compiled
symbols for the sake of having something
different right so then the function
compile would return compiled symbol and
then what you would do is instead of
calling F of 7 which would give you your
actual original definition you'd say
compiled symbol F of 7 and that would
give you the compiled version
sure something laughs but that's also
but you know it could equally well have
function compiled of F return a compiled
code function and then the compiled code
function applied to seven we know that
won't work cuz what about pattern
matching well the pattern matching is
going to be sort of you know sort of
factored into it you know what does it
actually return in other words if you
say cut um you know that will implement
the patterns as you you know dispatch
it'll dispatcher over the patterns
no but you're not answer my question
what what does it do I mean the whole
point is are you suggesting that we
overwrite the definition of f
[Music]
I mean I think that's one possible mode
but there's a core thing underneath of
that that returns a function
but really but what does it do if the
pattern match fails what does the
function return' well it does you know
it can call in the function dispatch
dispatch look Tom either if you've got a
definition okay wait wait a second if
you've got some down values okay they
only match certain patterns right right
okay so this is a long sort of missing
link is a pure function that rejects
certain arguments we've never had that
well we've never had that matching built
into pure functions that's that's what
we're talking about yes we've had a
design for 25 years so wait wait wait
are we planning to execute that because
that's a big deal which will affect a
lot of other parts of the system well
the compiler would do that no no no but
we can't do that we're not going to do
that we're not going to have some
special proboscis for compiled functions
for everything else
what's up the whole thing is a proboscis
no no no no look look I mean we could
perfectly well have if we wanted to just
like we have you know function XY X plus
y right we could imagine a syntax where
we do where this thing here is e it's
like e you'd write this write function
of e and then you would have rules like
like that match against e for example
what well I mean what I'm thinking of is
we can do things like this where where
this could perfectly well have a D
structuring things with that that does
that that does that because the pattern
the names of the pattern variables
become the objects in the body
okay wait wait you might have different
bodies
no I'm talking about yeah yeah big so
what you're suggesting is that there can
be a function whose which is an
association effectively that has various
pattern forms here
yeah yeah arrow you know yeah whatever
it is yeah yeah okay so that so in a
sense what that's doing is it's taking
the down values list
yeah yeah I mean this is the obvious
thing there are some differences in
scoping that would need to be you know
thought through butter the only way that
patent variables in down values scope is
unfortunatel a different from the way
the function variables scope but no no
but there's a different issue here which
is what does it do if none of the
patterns match so what you've done is
you've got this potion object and you're
applying two things
well I mean it could have a default I
mean there's a bunch of things we could
do we could have you know require a
catch-all case so it's not valid input
if there isn't for example we could do
that well that'd be a very different
kind of thing but yes okay look this is
not properly designed we should not be
experimental eyes the pure function case
until we've designed this because it may
affect the pure function then I don't
think we see the experimental eyes any
of the functions fine because they will
okay I mean I I think that you know I'm
hoping that before too long we will be
able to but but I think that two things
have to be true we have to understand
the down value case and by the way Tom I
mean it's been a year since we started
talking about the down value case it's
longer than that we talked about that on
day one you know you know I understand
that with specificity and and then what
we need to do here we need to get a
design for this down value case sure so
let's make sure in the next few weeks
that we talk about this so that we make
sure we know what we can talk about this
but you know we mustn't have a premature
design that then we find is a waste of
time
I hope it's not premature because I
thought there was the thing that was
going to be actually worked on real soon
yes fine when it's actively worked out
well remember there's twelve point one
out there and data structure and things
yeah I know I know
yeah no this is totally you know this is
the next thing our control point one in
data structure all right okay we have a
question on the live stream for Mohammed
asking what's the difference between
library Lincoln WS T P which is
something that actually relates to our
next topic of numeric array well I'm not
sure what it exactly rights to here okay
so WS TP is a transport protocol as its
name suggests it is what has been called
math link forever it was invented in
1989 it is the symbolic transport
protocol that allows one that all of the
link functions that like link open that
it's the way the front-end communicates
with the kernel it's wavy that a kernel
communicates with sub kernels and
parallel computing W STP supports all
the various operations that are needed
um to have rich communication like you
know what does it do if a dialogue is
started what does it do if messages are
passed library link on the other hand is
for calling binary programs at with
low-level data structures I don't know I
mean maybe there's a little bit more to
say about this because I mean after all
W STP does have a representation we have
the wrong people here to discuss the
details of this perhaps does have a
representation of many kinds of I mean
through STP has the concept of is about
sending symbolic expressions back and
forth library link well describe what it
does well I think you're focusing on the
wrong aspect because they can votes and
symbolic expressions and efficiently
transport you know low-level structures
like you know packed arrays the 3 PS
inter-process communication library link
is for dynamic library communication
basically
so there's a dynamic library with
library link but why is it the case that
library link does not support all the WS
DP syntax because you could want to just
it does you you can use a link object in
library one of the things you can have
is to use WS TP so in other words you
can use the C library bindings on the 2q
library Conal correct okay
but so what in fact oftentimes libraries
will you know if they need to you know
resi relays or something they'll use a
loopback link inside of their library
link library to do that sort of thing
okay so to what extent is the document
where is the documentation of library
link is this it
alright that's an overview that links to
many things
okay and there's some validly a guide
page linked to somewhere
this looks like it's bad formatting what
is this that looks like dad formatting
at the very least there's probably a
link to a guide page up at the top
actually related guides there you go and
why why is that grayed out so is anybody
who is Devon here let's see who's who is
yeah okay so that's one bug as that's
grayed out the second bug is those
headings are wrong okay
okay so can somebody talk through what's
on here
when they're mirror functions they're
get WS DP and process WS TP so basic and
in terms of sort of the C bindings
library link is a superset of WS DP the
difference I mean the main difference is
that library link is really for an in
process right you load the library into
the kernel process as opposed to
connecting to some other binary this is
really a pretty sad list here look at
all these different conventions and
random junk that's in here oh boy okay
okay so okay so what is our objective
here
I mean so Raj put these pages here
because he felt like he had to put the
pages here but I think this is an
irrelevant question because all of these
if you look all of those functions are
numeric arrays so if the underlying
numeric array is experimental and I
think the library links I don't even see
where the where the numeric array this M
numeric array clone is not listed here
why not I don't know I am surprised by
that maybe because I don't know if
that's just an oversight or if or if
because they were experimentally decided
about the link then I don't remember
okay so who is in charge of this page
and who's in charge of getting those
who's in charge of library link right
now what's that library link in general
I think top maybe Thomas not what
youngest Tom Thomas working only on the
compiler but we have been adding what's
wrong I guess we can be in charge
reviving all the numeric array functions
if you think adding experimental
function so it is yes that's yes because
they linked from the tutorial if you
could I don't yeah
I don't care they're not on the guide
page and they should be okay and they
also should be probably a separate guide
page for these C language language
functions that groups them in a nice way
and so on because they're a bunch more
of these functions I agree that yeah I
was gonna suggest some stop sectioning
there will definitely be nice and I
don't I mean this is complicated and
okay somebody has to be in charge of all
of this functionality who is it
is Todd gaily part of the story or what
no so so I would say from a code
perspective Rob is in charge but
Charlie's group as the heaviest
consumers has been largely in charge of
the documentation can I call you sir
libel Inc is probably going to become
obsolete as well I mean compile code
function does all of this better
if you could see me you would see me
rolling my eyes well right I'm telling
you I've no doubt you're rolling your
eyes okay would you like to excite about
me Tom am I also rolling my eyes
I have no idea why you you roll them
quite a lot yeah okay explain the
statement tom um I'm just saying that
the interfacing to you know code loaded
into the kernel that's exactly what
compiled code functions doing
okay but there's an analysis of okay so
on the client on the side of the of the
okay so what we've got you can make
since 1989 an installable program using
a template file or using raw W STP
commands in the C code yes correct
correct okay
if you've got an installable program is
it the case that you can use library
link to load that installable program
into the memory space of you're running
no that's that's not correct
that's quite not incorrect why not
because the install the program isn't
executable and library link works with
libraries not with executables right if
your program was architected such that
it could the main executable only loaded
a you know a single library and then ran
that library then it is conceivable that
you could change you can build your
thing in two ways
conveniently right but I mean the write
a program if it's in the program it has
its own main it has right all the extra
stuff of being an actual executable
program and you can't just low the
second main into your add you know into
your own process space wait a minute
doesn't doesn't when you use W STP
doesn't it create a separate main for
you I seem to remember that template
files which I made up bad sure but that
goes in the external prorate WS DP
launches an external executable and and
communicates with it yes there's a thing
called M prep which helps you do that
from some non WL specification right but
that's that's a thing that is invoked by
the C compiler
um isn't that correct well the C
compiler will make whatever you want it
can make a library or an executable no
no no mmm prep em prep is invoked by you
or prot in probably in most cases by
your made file to make a dot MC file
that is comes from the template file
correct right either a dot C or the C X
X depending on which language you're
using right and that converts the dot TM
into either a dot C or a dot C X X and
then you apply your favorite compiler to
that right okay right I remember
so that mechanism is thirty years old so
explain library link relative to that
mechanism so that is a completely
different write it and it's right it's
an intra process it's a different
mechanism you have your dot C which will
include Wolfram Library dot H I think is
the is the main header and possibly item
sub headers and you compiled that and
you do not create an executable you
create just a dot o file no I don't s o
or DLL or diner
okay it's fine but so what are the entry
points and that look like though you the
library exports functions and you call
those functions from the kernel so if
you look at that first example demo is
the name of a library and demo III is
the name of a function in that library
okay so kind of on the cell surface so
to speak of the DLL is a demo i I tagged
correct yes correct a function yes right
whereas in the case of W STP the only
exposed surface is you know main arc CRE
is that correct well really I mean from
the kernels point of view the only thing
that's really exposed is the the link
object right you call it and you give it
command yeah I guess art the art see is
is relevant but actually that's not
correct because in a template file
you can specify multiple functions so
there is obviously a protocol that calls
in to the main program and says which
function you are trying to call yeah
there's one main function that gets
created and that dispatches to
individual functions as opposed to the
library link case where each individual
piece of executable code has a
separately exposed tag that says that it
is callable from the outside world yeah
yeah that's good right and and in
particular right the way the kernel
calls it right it you know calls the
right so one of the things in prep does
is embed argument you know aren't V
handling for managing links so the
kernel will call the external program
with appropriate options so that they to
open a link and then all the
communication basically happens over
that link as opposed to in library link
you directly load this function and bind
it to you know this library function and
then you call library function which
will dispatch into the da des Eaux or
that I Lib okay right so one question is
okay the the bad documentation of
library link that's one issue
second issue is consistency between
three things now we've got W STP we've
got library link and we've got
apparently the compiler
the compiler relate to so didn't didn't
Christopher have some projects yes and
he'd find that immensely he'd find it
immensely easier now I mean now it what
was his project again to implement
external function foresee using this
mechanism is that correct you using the
compiler it would work very well can you
describe the project please
well what Christopher was trying to do
was he was trying he was doing you know
he was having a library and he was
building an interface to that library
and putting a compiled code function
around
as a way to call that library as a way
to call that library but doing it sort
of automatically based upon
introspecting header files I guess a
women it was taking see source code with
its header files and analyzing those
header files to generate a type
declaration that could then be used
automatically by something in library
link no no it would be directly it was
generating a function that was then
compiled and so how do things like
memory management work for that well no
different from any of these so you know
different
if you want to connect things through
into expressions then that's that's what
data structure does
what wait a second wait a second wait a
second when certain functions yeah but
but let's imagine that we're calling an
external si program with some giant
tensor that's had that who allocates the
memory for that tensor right then the
external program would allocate and when
you finished with it you would have to
remember to call deallocate tensor why
why why when the thing exits it's
finished I don't understand both of them
allocated right the kernel allocates it
because it creates this expression and
then when you send it over math link and
as it's receiving this tensor over the
link the external program will you know
but it's not true for library link as
well
that it doesn't have shared memory I
thought I'd shared memory it does okay
so what's the relationship between
numeric array and isn't it the case that
you can have a numeric array that
appears to be in standard Wolfram
language memory space but yet is acted
upon by C code and that's great without
copying that's that's correct okay so
explain then in Christopher's project or
in the compiler what is the analogous
thing so wcp it has to copy the
left-hand side I can see this in the
zone I'm disappointed by the fact that
has to be a disown right okay so I'm
asking why does there have to be a
disown why is it not that the memory is
managed in other words because C is not
a garbage-collected language so you you
have to have some way for the C code to
tell the kernel that it's finished with
something otherwise that numeric array
might get closed did Christopher did not
have a solution to that
Christopher's system even though it
could automatically read the the header
files and figure out the types of all
the variables and things it did not have
a mechanism for automatically disowning
things or did it I think it must be done
otherwise it'll be many memory
the Steven I think the basic answer to
your question is void star right I mean
in C you can write you can pass around
memory there's no notion of whether the
memory is owned or not so if you're
executing arbitrary C code you know you
have to have some responsibility for
declaring okay I'm actually done with
this I understand that but if the memory
is shared well I get it I get it I get
it I mean I get it that the that there's
it could be the case that you will
recall that C program and you want the C
program to still have that thing in
memory absolutely that's that's why even
though the thing was removed on the
Wolfram language side even though the
woman language things said we know how
many more pointers to this we don't have
any more links to this you can can get
rid of it yeah yeah that's that's
exactly correct so it can be free a ball
on the Wolfram language side but not
Fria belong the sea side right and
having an activity zone you know it
prevents it from being collected in the
kernel all right so let's let's walk
through again the role of library link
so I mean we think the documentation is
not up to snuff but to what extent is
the code base of library link being and
we're not rewriting that code base we're
simply in providing an interface to it
through the compiler is that a true
statement you mean we're not going to
get to it anytime in the next five years
so basically that we're not pointing out
people spend
add new types to library link every six
months and it takes the months of work
to add one type okay I don't really care
I mean the question that I'm asking what
is the plan what what's the overall plan
with respect to the compiler and library
link and WS DP what is the what is the
goal that does our mind wise I mean I WS
the PSD is fundamentally different let's
put that on the side okay library link
versus the compiler
okay I would I would never use Snivy
link I would always use the okay okay is
every piece of functionality in library
link now available in the compiler the
names of the functions aren't but I
think I think you can do very equivalent
things and work so why don't we make a
binding where we have the names of those
functions yeah we get so that let me
understand what would then be possible
so are you what would be the analog
we've got library function load what is
the analog of that in the compiler well
the compiler works with functions so to
do library function load you would you
know it would need some amount of work
but you would create a function that
took the expression interface and you
know you know denatured it according to
length and type but it would be it would
be immensely faster okay hold on hold on
I want to know with specificity okay
okay right now people have C code that
has library link functions in it right
right okay and that C code is then taken
it is created as a DLL they use the C
compiler to make a DLL then they use
library function load to load that DLL
into the into our address space and then
and that exposes an interface to the
function which is then called and
something has to know what food is fed
to that function right what what what
stores the information on what kind of
you know what kind of diet the function
has what structure of data structures
get sent to it and so on so there's
there's coding the Conal that does that
there's coding the C functions that does
that as well but this code in the C
functions is quite awkward okay hold on
hold on I'm asking a different question
in the case of you know what used to be
math link which I remember because I you
know designed it in 1989 the way that
works is it exposes an installable
program exposes essentially patterns
that determine what can be what it's
diet is what can be fed right right
right okay what is the analog of that
for a library link dll what is the
analog of that for a function built
library link dll so basically the this
the C signature of the function
determines whether it can consume okay
so it's a Rossi signature not the
signature of the functions is all the
same different significant then why they
comin in argument things eat are you
could look at some of the examples even
if you want to know okay well let me
show you an example then where is it
we'll go into the user guide and you
know Wolfram and there's like look at
say there's probably a simple example no
we're pretty quickly a memory management
that best more comfy enough unction
arguments and results right so there
demo I I all these functions have the
same signature
what is what is ement eyes your machine
integer okay but so that's our data type
that's our datatype correct where do we
have a documentation of our data types
[Music]
okay that's kind of link called type
specification yeah in the middle
slightly below where your cursor yeah
yeah there we go
that's a design mess anyway okay okay
easily that function Steven it's written
with this mint oxy M argument args and
argument rows so this isn't a rossi
function this is a c function that has
to be read as their markets away what is
what is M argument it's a union a
describes in this thing it's a union of
all the it's described right underneath
but could it be an arbitrary struct or
not no it's a union of one of those
types M argument get integer is like the
W STP get integer thing is that correct
well in what sense like it's well in the
sense that if you have a manual in the
case of a template file from 30 years
ago right there's the idea of sending
there's certain types which can be
specified in the template file if you
want a more complicated data structure
you have to manually get that data
structure off the link things off the
link I don't understand this the gates
integer will return an integer even if
there isn't a linting integer being
written out I understand that but this
is the analog of this args thing appears
to be just a this is what a mess I mean
this is just a raw piece in memory that
just happens to have those types in it
but nostro it's basically a caste it's
saying read this argument as an integer
yeah I get it I get it
and those but those things are just a
blob of memory that happens to be able
to store any of those native types
basically yeah but M tensor could be an
arbitrary sized object so I'm very
confused by no it's a pointer not a size
it's an address but they're all pointers
here no
not well women said star integer so it's
a pointer to that's just to give him a
uniform packing size right are they like
all the you know apes have the same size
right everything in the Union has the
same size so everything that's literally
in the Union is the same size because
it's a pointer to the actual data right
and I'm sure that the definition of them
argument get integer is something like
reference meant of starters start an
argument or something like that
okay once again I asked okay so let's
take a look here at the analogous thing
um okay so let's look at um I want to
look at the C language functions
probably know this thing okay so this is
the old 30 year old template file
mechanism right it's pretty clean
actually well it's not why isn't it
Wolfram language like why is it a wacky
alternative language these days it would
be a Wolfram language right that's
that's okay I mean it could be written
in top level now quite easily yes it
could be yeah could easily be but it's
nice and you know this is nice and easy
to read here and now it will be an
association um but but the point here is
this is a declaration I mean it's really
very simple what you give here in the
actual this is the native name in the C
code of that function right I'm making
sense
and this is simply saying what will be
put on the stack to be passed to that
function by making sense
sure
but again the whole point is that this
is all carefully managed right you're
not well it's not true no there's a
manual case here where you are
explicitly feeding things over I don't
whether it's cover here but but where
you're explicitly feeding things over
let's take a look here okay that's
evaluation sure I mean you can't you
don't have to use template files you can
yeah little bit but even in template
class you can have a manual mode in
which you are explicitly picking and
getting putting and getting structures
from the link which is I think
presumably analogous to M numeric array
get data
no no why not they like array gets the
raw data in the numeric array that's
what this does when you get the thing
from the link you say you know W STP get
integer for example it gets the integer
right and it returns a Mathematica
integer no it doesn't it returns a
c-code integer return to see integer
that you put into there's nothing in W
STP that returns an address of data that
was written that's not true it's not
true there's a bunch of things that do
that's how you deal with any data
structure that isn't explicitly there
anything you couldn't pass on the stack
and see you give a pointer to and it
works the same way no you iterate over
it it tells you a number of arguments it
tells you what the head is you know that
thing's that's one way of doing it I
think you okay fair enough fair enough
oh boy guys we have slightly different
things you see W STP is serializing and
deserializing and sterilizing it's a
serialization interface okay
API interface so the bottom line is
we've got several things running around
here and they need proper design we've
got the external function mechanism the
Christopher started building which I
think had a pretty good design idea yeah
that's an interesting way to go would go
a lot further now
well maybe we should I mean Todd and his
merry band are the people who would be
building that so maybe we can re you
know maybe we can look at that again but
the way that would work to a user is
you've got a lump of C code and this
would you would declare something that
says which functions you are trying to
expose correct yeah no no let's walk
through it in more detail right the
header file and a library right but the
end result is that you will have an
external function that just like right
now you might have an external function
that refers to the Python interpreter
for example right like like for example
I could say here if I'm not mistaken
something like um maybe somebody can
help me with this external function I
don't know the name of any Python
function what's the name of Python
function give me a give me a python
function print know something something
that does an operation on data like a
string to to ask you or something well
ABS I've got that here yes alright so
then okay so then this is the external
function right and that external
function now is you know will do its
thing right
and this will blow up probably hell it
worked
amazing oh it passed it probably passed
it correctly as a okay in any case so
what this is doing is it is okay it is
it has a running Python session it's
sending those functions so the idea was
that if you have a C binary that has
more specialized functions that it
supports this is the generic Python
interpreter but the idea would be that
it looks like external function of C
executable and then some entry point but
but there's a big difference here
external function here knows that it's
going to Python so it knows how to
serialize and deserialize between
Wolfram language and Python in in some
unwashed C I know I know I know I know
so you have got to get something here
which is a DLL or it is some external
program that could be a separate process
but it has to have had its its interface
defined right so you know this could be
a my program dot exe
here and then it could be which has had
which has been created by something that
knows how to deal with an ABS here right
that's just like the installable program
mechanism right that's that's like
calling an external program am I making
sense
not to me okay let's go through this
again alright so in the case of install
right what you do is given install so
that an install actually will expose
these functions it's still bootstraps
itself yes but but there is a low-level
function called what is it called what
is the function that actually sends
something to install do you understand
what I'm talking about
desert there's a thing I can't remember
what it's called now um that when you
invoke install the program it doesn't
bootstrapping definitions yes I know
that I know that if you look at the
result of an install you will see the
thing that it does if you actually look
at that definition yeah yeah you if you
look at the code that's generated you
can see that that's not the C code if I
say um if I say here what the heck is
this not working anymore
why does it not show me that missing
unknown symbol I'm totally confused here
this documentation needs to be rerun but
but what I'm looking for
I think it's called external call or
something it's the thing that's actually
in that that is actually in the down
values wrong
I don't understand that I don't
understand where it went
maybe it's protected or something but
any case the okay um okay we've had a
bunch of comments on our livestream here
um comments about graphics being real
measurement aware that we had a long
discussion about what was it last week
it's much more complicated than you can
possibly imagine sadly because we don't
know how big the screen is
um complaints about WS TP and links
issues of connecting remote kernels to a
front-end improvements on that front for
12.1 that's good there's still more
streamlining to be done there complaints
about poor documentation for library
link and so on an entry point takes the
name of a module yeah yeah I agree
um right um okay so look we've got
several things going on here I think
let's let's have a separate discussion
about this mess of how we actually you
know you know whether we can use and all
these things which say oh we just need
to do a little bit of work that's not
good enough
we've got to actually provide something
the alternatives they're huge amounts of
work in some other way
no no we've got we got a bunch of stuff
that already works although it's very
bad I don't care the I mean the the
factors
look what we've got to do is clean up
we've got to have a clean uniform way to
do this whether it is using quotes
library link or whether it's using
quotes the compiler or whether it's
using some combination of these I don't
know if somebody thinks they already
have an idea how to do this that will be
great
does anybody think they have that idea
well but your yes is throwaway library
link use the compiler okay what is your
what - what is your what is your road
map for what to do well I think new data
types that people want to add you know
shouldn't be added tonight well I'm
asking you what are we doing with
library link what are we doing with the
compiler well just saying that you can
add a new data type in the compiler is
irrelevant we've already got a lot of
stuff in library link either we have all
that stuff working in the compiler and
an interface that provides all the
capabilities of library link in the
compiler framework all we don't the cost
eval your new data type to library
linking and I know then the course
that's not the point we're not
addressing you're not addressing the
point I'm making are you saying that we
should throw away library link and move
all its functionality to the compiler or
are you saying something different I'm
saying we should consider you know no no
no no no I'm asking the question I just
asked
what's the answer to that question are
you suggesting right away does you know
it sounds like I don't care what it
sounds like you're basically saying all
the functionality now available through
library link is quotes easy but although
it hasn't been done to make available
through the compiler is that a true
statement yeah okay what would be
involved in making it available through
the compiler we were writing Wolfram
language code and compile it into
something okay so let's be specific what
would it look like we would have a new
library here although we might we might
if we want
change the interface to library that
would also make sense okay so wait a
second so we would have two things then
we would have a new it new interface and
we would also have bindings for the
existing library that have a different
implementation is that correct I think
it would make sense to keep the old one
it's necessary because we have a lot of
programs that use library link so what
we would do is compile them against a
new library basically support the new
approach here's what I'm saying Steven
if you want to build something like M
prep for library link it would be
student you know it would be stupid to
actually do that for library links that
would make more sense in the compiler
yeah and what I'm trying to be specific
here no no I'm trying to be specific
what we're doing what you are suggesting
doing is taking the functionality of
library link right and using the
compilers mechanism for type declaration
well it's not that it's using the
compilers mechanism for working with
expressions that's useful that's what
you said so so let's be specific let's
okay against Steven can I ask you a
question so say say I'm pure and I have
I know
40 different library link packets now if
you do whatever magic it is you you
think you you can or and or should do in
the compiler what do I is pure have to
do to my library link programs to make
them work with your stuff well if you
want them to work as written without
change then you do nothing that's not
true you have to recompile them against
a new library the library link code
whatever code there is in library assume
it's not in the distribution what do you
have to do it's only compiler code
that's in the distribution well it'll be
entirely feasible to have a compiler way
of interfacing with the legacy
you know stupid Union thing that we have
but wouldn't it be nice if you didn't
have no no no no I'm not interested in
that I want to know the answer to it
eyes question right we've got existing
library link code well what is it could
work mean well an exact code is sitting
there
there are dot s old files that exist or
DLL files I don't know what they're
called in all these environments there
are DLL files that sit there there in
some packets
how are those DLL files being called
right now there is code that says
library function load is there not that
loads those library function yes right
okay that code what happens to that code
so you would be compiled code that does
no no no no no I'm asking the question
right now in the packet we have the
function library library function load
right yes
do we still have the function library
function load or do we have something
different in the future that's not to
use even if you want library function
loads you that could be implemented
relevant okay all right but but so but
it would be merely a wrapper around what
it would be wrapper around some Wolfram
language code that would be compliant
what would the function be called that
it is a wrapper around library function
load is something which says there is an
external program it sits in this file
and now I want to load it so that it is
callable from Wolfram language code what
is the analog of that for the compiler
well it could be function load it could
be whatever you want I don't know but
I'm trying to understand in your model
there is something there is a piece of
external code that is a scent that's
that's a div meter to have it with type
annotations like typed you know rather
than this sort of rather whacky integer
type of thing that that might be better
no no no no you've got the mechanism
kernel function which is a way of
calling back into the kernel from
compiled code right okay so the issue is
you've got a random floating dll out
there okay different from what you have
for compiled code because compiled code
is simply in the memory space in Wolfram
language memories no that's not true
Stephan you can have a data structure
isn't in the mem you know data structure
is turned into a dynamic library and
loaded into the do you look at the
compiler documentation for compile
function export library that's that's
exactly what it's doing okay fine so
what is the way that you need a
structure Steven data structure running
the compiler you're loading a library
click compile function external library
export how do you run the result of
compiled function library export well at
the moment you do library function load
just on the library and that extracts
the function and you okay so you're
using you're using the stuff from by
example looking the documentation of for
what compile function library function
compile export library we designed this
you and I I remember right so you okay
library function load so you're using
the very same function yeah it uses
the same function as our convenience and
you just give it the library and that
generates a load function fine and let
you see the interface that you give to
it is like typed it's a bit nicer than
this sort of you know bracket you know
and says it doesn't say integer okay
okay Tom wait for a second
inside this d-y Lib yes then the C code
that piata would write that is on that
side of it yes
so something here that is the
Declaration on the Wolfram language side
of the interface to the internal code in
here correct inside function D while
loop the second inside function D eyelid
there is a function that has a that's
the body of that you know aren't +1 yes
ok so this is creating a library okay
this is doing the whole thing okay yes
let's imagine that I was writing
external C code right that will expose a
single argument typed machine integer
right so you could one way of doing this
you would have some specification of the
interface and it might be nicer to use
typed and you would have that's another
thing that references the library that
you're wanting to suck in okay so that's
extremely close to template files from
30 years ago yes yes yes okay
I'm agreeing with you okay so let's be
practical about what that could be
so imagine that in not okay so you have
to expose that in the C code basically
and something has to harvest it and
create an interface from it correct in
the in the you mean in the in the kernel
C no no no no no no no no no the C code
that piata whoever is writing for some
random piece of functionality right
something has to tell it this is it has
to say in that C code because that's a
convenient place to put it this is the
interface that I wish to expose correct
he writes his library and uses standard
C ways you declare something as extern
or or if it's in a dynamic library you
know there's a few wait a second wait a
second wait a second okay so what
Christopher was doing was to read the C
code and deduce from that what the
interface should be yeah huge reading
header files yes I believe yeah right
okay so one problem with that is the
disowning of memory is not handled by
that that's that problem is common to
all of these things okay great
how do you plan on solving it happens
with template files
it happens with library link well it
doesn't have the template file template
files doesn't happen with template files
it does not happen with template files
because they deal with creating they are
dealing with single function calls right
and unless you use manual if you give an
array of integers for example there it
is responsible upon return from the
function for program you might want data
to live from one I'm aware of that
that's when you use the manual case of a
template file yes an automatic mechanism
where it is a single call where the
memory is allocated and D allocated when
the function is called and when it
returns but I think math link has
disowned functions as well Tom Tom
you're missing the point I'm saying look
in the default case memory is allocated
okay in the default case for WS TP
memory is allocated at the time when the
function is called and D allocated when
it returns for everything
Tom I wrote this stuff that he is
I know how it works and it well I will
point out that was thirty years ago and
we've had at least two major interfaces
since then so okay I know that in the
case of arrays that's how it worked when
you could not pass the thing using that
was the whole idea of how the template
file was architected was to give people
the expectation manage get string WS get
string Steven I'm sure that it has a
disowned string P support hazard disown
it has a release WS really string it
that's all I'm saying
yes okay some of these things go back
let's go back already
hold on let's go back to what we were
talking about okay so your proposal is
that P Otis code which right now is full
of M numeric array get data and things
like this right would merely have it's C
data type declarations right well he he
might want to know that he's getting a
numeric array and be cognate you might
want to create a numeric array and
return it so he might be calling the
function similar functions to the ones
that you see on the left hand side I'm
are functions I'm aria colonel I'm
asking if all he is doing is getting
data from the colonel and they'll heat
what he could do is take his see data
structures okay
and automatically have those see data
structures read and create an interface
to them that would work here so no
declarations are ever needed except the
ones in the secret but Piazza might have
taught them and I don't care what he
might have I'm asking whether that case
would work
which case the one I just described he's
probably going okay you've got a piece
of C code
it's got declarations in it yes okay I
don't know what happens with memory
management but let's assume it's stuff
that's passed on the stack okay and I
hope the otter is here and can can
respond to this I'm here I'm listening
okay all right so you've got Rossy code
it's got declarations in it the whole
point is you could in principle read
those headers read those decorations and
create the interface completely
automatically true or not yes okay thank
you
all right first point we're clear on
that okay all right now I'm sorry yes
okay so that's first point second point
for data that has to be explicitly
allocated we need a mechanism for
dealing with that
correct that would be I'm sorry yes I'm
agree okay
in modern C++ and so on which I don't
know very well how does that work
do they have a mechanism of doing that
or still calling raw Malik yeah where
you call something that's more
abstracted like like new a constructor
basically you still have the same issue
okay but but so you explicitly call that
so there's a there's a pointer that you
might pass on the stack but then the
actual memory allocation is happening
through some constructor C++ doesn't add
much you know it adds more stuff but no
new college it so in that case
presumably there is a declaration of
what that new constructor returns
correct yes okay so there is a data
structure declaration somewhere there
which could in principle be read to
create something which is an expose
about data structure representation
right now you're asking specifically
about C++ well yes oh so now you're
rapidly getting into very hairy
complicated things way beyond what
Christopher was looking at you might
have templates you might have classes
you might have mixtures of templates and
classes you're in Paree territory you
have lost a lot of the things to you
like private and public data too okay so
what is your proposal guys right now we
have a working solution with library
link except that it's grown over the
years it's kind of a mess things are not
very compatible that guide page is an
embarassment etc right but we've got
that model now what are you proposing
as you know what's the modernization of
that
well the modernization of that would be
to generate code top-level functions
that take expressions that that you know
denature them into the calls into your C
code and compile that
wait but I I don't understand that I
mean I have some external library I want
to write I still I want to utilize I
don't understand what workflow you are
proposing for me you mean do you mean
developing the code using it was no
we've got an existing piece of code and
we want to write glue code that will
connect it to that allows it to be
callable from inside our language and no
it's taking it has complicated data
structures and it has to pass back with
library link you're none of these
proposals whitey tie all these
extensions to library link are purely
designed to take kernel kernel data
structures and expose them out
not taking not going in the other way
around you've got to understand that oh
wait a minute wait a minute sorry right
now I have taken many libraries many
external libraries and interfaced them
to our language
correct correct yes and I'm changing the
the native see data structures into our
mm numeric array or M tensor I have to
do that but that's the big piece of the
C code that we're writing okay so what
does that look like roughly when you do
that when when you then you're you're
writing and interface which takes those
data structures and then you're
essentially explaining how to turn that
into the native C data structures of
whatever library you're using right well
right if I may I think a better way to
say it is he's writing functions which
take data from the kernel and then call
the functions from the library and then
if you know take those results and
return them to the kernel is that a fair
assessment pure what right that that's
well scenario that you only transfer the
data structure that you have in the
kernel to the C code and possibly maybe
store it in a file in
specific four-month okay so one thing
that would be helpful to you perhaps is
if the specification of the Wolfram
language aside data structures was made
using or actually either sides data
structures was made using modern
compiler typed this that and the other
stuff rather than this kind of nest of
raw function calls that you probably are
using right now and library link you
know what I have to go I'm really late
for something else um let's please well
I just thought maybe last thing I want
to point out that we are using a lot of
C++ libraries and obviously we have to
convert at some point the C++ data
structure classes into what we have here
that is our M numeric array or M tensor
or M image but as Tom already said it's
not easy to take the C++ DLL and use
compiler for that that the Mangler issue
and all of this we know it's it's so
it's okay for C libraries and we get a
separate meeting specifically about this
whole topic of calling external programs
and hopefully you guys can prepare some
proposal for what how this could be
designed okay and let's take it from
that to people here we should definitely
have Rob in that and Todd okay um all
right let's see the Brian is is
mentioning c-sharp yes
well c-sharp we have a whole separate
the whole dotnet framework we have all
separate mechanism for dealing with um
yeah I mean this is a jungle
you know realistically this is you know
the whole point is that we have over the
last 30 something years built this we
hope
shiny wonderful you know thing but
there's a jungle outside and my analogy
is falling apart um but
- yeah it's complicated interfacing with
all these different things um but okay
let's let's let's meet and talk about
this again and I'm really embarrassed by
that library link guide page and part of
our plan needs to be what we're going to
do to fix that and to actually document
some of these functions and put them on
the guide page alright thanks guys
thanks to people on the livestream will
actually be back in about 40 minutes for
another livestream meeting talk to y'all
soon see ya bye